[Musica]
Buonasera
Che bello essere qui tra di voi in
questo mese di settembre 2022
in questo bel teatro di Bologna
E pensare che sono morto nel 1892
anche se c'è chi dice che io
Walt whitman avendo scritto versi
immortali sono a mia volta eterno
un mitico Bardo che prende vita ogni
volta che un lettore legge le mie foglie
d'Erba
e i miracoli della poesia
miracoli
c'è forse tra voi qualcuno che crede nei
miracoli Sì
eventi mistici magici misteriosamente
soprannaturali quelli che accadono ai
santi di cui vanno raccontando i
predicatori
pani e pesci che si moltiplicano
morti che resuscitano per davvero in
carne ed ossa malati che guariscono per
volontà Divina
apparizioni celesti che guidano il
destino degli uomini
io
no no no no no no io no non certo io
o forse tra voi c'è qualcuno che crede
che gli eventi cosiddetti miracolosi
siano altri la forza delle macchine di
ogni tipo che portano gli uomini a
navigare cieli e abissi le luci che
illuminano di giorno la città
le onde elettromagnetiche invisibili che
abbracciano la terra e fanno viaggiare
parole suoni immagini
io
Oh no no no no no no no no no no io no
non certo io
o meglio Questi sono i miracoli
ragionevoli miracoli che si possono
spiegare con la ragione miracoli
dell'ingegno del sudore della
perseveranza umana
Proprio come i primi sono i miracoli
della superstizione quei miracoli che si
possono spiegare
rinunciando alla ragione
per paura debolezza
forse semplicità
per quieto vivere
Lo so lo so lo so sto dicendo cose che
contraddicono quello che dimessi
racconta nei libri di letteratura
il poeta più famoso del trascendente
americano l'autore che coi suoi versi ha
dato forma agli Stati Uniti
un po' come un Dio che crea qualcosa che
prima non c'era
uno che fa miracoli
Ma quale miracolo quale miracolo Io non
ho fatto altro che guardare e raccontare
il mio mondo
che poi nella sua essenza più profonda
non era tanto diverso dal vostro
ho guardato il mio mondo
e forse questo il mio evento miracoloso
ma non c'è nulla di sovrumano nulla di
trascendente nell'ammirare il mondo
a ben guardare
ammirar bene però
forse lì che sta il miracolo
vedete ha ben guardare
a ben ammirare Sì ci penso più credo che
questo sia il modo giusto per raccontare
il mio miracolo
Mentre il mondo si apriva ai nuovi
miracoli della ragione e mentre gli
umani si consolavano con gli antichi
miracoli della superstizione io io
ho Ammirato il mondo
con lo stupore di chi si accorge di
essere vivo
semplicemente toccando un filo d'erba
guardando i cielo oltre i tetti
camminando a pieni nudi sulla sabbia
proprio sul filo dell'acqua
riparandomi sotto gli alberi del Bosco
condividendo il cibo con gli amici con
dividendo il letto con chi amo
sorridendo agli estranei sul tram
spiando le api In estate gli alveari
ammirando gli animali mentre pascolano
il volo degli uccelli
incantandomi al tramonto la luna nuova
in aprile
camminando per la via della mia città
e ancora e ancora e ancora
incantandomi ad ogni ora di buio e di
luce
ho Ammirato il mondo e mi sono guardato
intorno
e ho scelto ho scelto così di vivere e
di condividere
ho scelto di essere e di esserci ogni
istante ogni giorno consapevolmente
è questo il vero miracolo la rivelazione
stupefacente in attesa di come ogni
gesto che facciamo tutti i giorni
racchiuda già in sé tutte le meraviglie
del mondo
se solo sappiamo compiere con la
consapevolezza
e con l'intensità di chi sa vivere
responsabilmente
è questo ancora ed ancora il solo unico
vero miracolo della mia poesia forse
trascendentale certo sicuramente
tangibile viva e nuova ad ogni lettura
il problema vedete
Il problema è l'abitudine ai miracoli di
tutti i giorni perché gli umani
finiscono per darle per scontata per
vederla come una cosa normale
un fondale di sopravvivenza
ma è qui
È qui che entra in gioco il poeta a
questo serve la poesia a capire il
miracolo di ogni cosa che esiste e
poteva non esistere
e ci siamo abituati a guardarla come
ordinaria
quello che abbiamo sotto gli occhi è
davvero miracoloso
le persone che incontriamo
poter parlare con loro
poter ridere e piangere con loro
questa sera
non è miracoloso il fatto che io sia qui
tra di voi pur essendo morto 130 anni fa
il vero miracolo siete voi
con le vostre vite
il fatto che siete vivi
il fatto che guardate che ascoltate
che Respirate
Io sono qui solamente per ricordarvi di
ricordarlo
spero che quando uscirete da questo
teatro
continuerete a pensare a me è la mia
poesia come hai custodi dei Miracoli
delle vostre esistenze perché
la musica più bella
Ma la musica più bella
è la musica di ciò che accade
[Applauso]